here's what's going on at the movies  it's a class for oppression that's okay  she seems peaceful the supernatural  comedy Ghostbusters is back and features  some of the funniest characters  strapping on a proton pack experienced  Ghostbusters in IMAX 3d this is what I  do I'm an undercover narcotics agent I  live for suspense and drama  Chuck out the infiltrator based on  real-life events surrounding the biggest  drug sting in history drugs will not be  tolerated  comedy drama and romance are all on  display in Woody Allen's Cafe Society  about a young man swept up in the  vibrant scene of 1930s Hollywood  yes politely people listened and finally  let's find out what's hot in theaters  this weekend with this week's fan tip  the patient  but what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket